the right wing hate mob that has been
Unleashed against me
by Donald Trump Jr and Candace Owens and
others listen I'm a big boy I can take
comments on Twitter right but they are
going after our advertisers
and they actually are succeeding to some
degree
some advertisers have already canceled
they don't know what's going on they're
just getting thousands of emails from
people on the right who don't even watch
this show but have been weaponized by
people like Don Jr and Candace Owens
over my uh tweet regarding the Nashville
shooting wherein I was blaming those who
offer only thoughts and prayers and
nothing else now as I've said before
it is a fine legal tactic to use to go
to a Show's advertisers and say you
shouldn't advertise with this person uh
it was a tactic that was used in the
past with Tucker Carlson Etc but use it
when it's appropriate and what is
happening right now and we have we have
examples of this I'm not going to put a
ton of them up but if you look on
Twitter all of these right-wing and
white nationalist accounts are listing
sponsors and then contacting the
sponsors and saying these aren't my
viewers nor are they customers of these
Brands but they are saying you gotta
drop David Pacman now we are doing
everything we can to explain to them
these aren't our viewers and these
aren't your customers this is a
concerted effort in fact even Candace
Owens is leading this effort to some
degree tweeting as I told you earlier to
any of your advertisers who may be
following this this is not a contrived
mob yes it is or anti-Semitism look at
my inbox Candace this is you dealing
with the consequences of sending the
most horrifically bigoted tweet directed
at dead Christian children who according
to you should have prayed harder of
course not my point I I would never
blame the victims of a mass shooting you
all know that but that's what they want
to make it out to be so what we have now
is a situation where we know this is a
contrived mob the video I did about the
situation received nearly a hundred
percent likes versus dislikes because
our audience gets all of it the people
who aren't viewers and aren't customers
of these Brands though
are having success we already got emails
from multiple advertisers saying we are
pausing advertising pausing means it's
over okay this is the most desperate
situation we have ever had over right
Wingers desperate not to deal with gun
safety because understand that that's
what this is they would rather focus on
anything other than gun safety
regulations to prevent shootings in the
future
that's what this is about
and so instead they're going after me
they're more angry about a tweet I sent
saying thoughts and prayers do nothing
to stop shootings than they are about
the dead kids and now they're going
after my advertisers rather than trying
to fix the problem so what you can do
number one write to our advertisers the
ones you see at the end of videos write
to them and say
please keep advertising with David the
people emailing you angry aren't even
his viewers nor are they your customers
second subscribe to the YouTube channel
if we can weather this with a big
increase in subscribers at a time when
the right is trying to end us
it would be huge and the most important
thing is we have to replace that Revenue
we have this is no longer theoretical
this is not about you know it's nicer to
get support from the audience because
then no one person can well listen we
have a mix of support from different
sources advertisers are one of those and
one person can say we're cutting the
campaign and that's what's happening
with a number of these campaigns it is
not theoretical
help us make up for a slice of what
these right-wing radicals have taken
away through the ad campaigns you go to
joinpakman.com we have a coupon code the
code is cancel cancel the cancelers who
say don't cancel people
they are the ones who say don't use
these techniques don't contact
advertisers demanding what they are now
doing
okay the coupon code is cancel cancel
this is genuinely
a systemic threat to the David Pacman
show in a week's time I will come back
to you and tell you if and to what
degree we have weathered it Don Jr quite
literally Don Jr is part of the hate mob
trying to end this show that is the
level that this has now reached so I'm
coming to you for support my audience
understands exactly what is going on uh
write to the advertisers subscribe to
the YouTube channel sign up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code
cancel cancel I will keep everybody
posted about what's going on My Hope Is
My Hope Is
that we actually come out of this even
stronger which will really upset the
right wing mob